so
play it by
good afternoon and welcome to at yale
live i'm eric gershon
the way we produce and market food
influences our diet and health and also
the health of the land and the
environment itself
mark bomford is director of the yale
sustainable food project which among
other things operates yale farm
today which is national food day we'll
talk with him about food sustainable
agriculture and the role universities
can play in improving what we eat and
how we get food
as always we'll pose some of your
questions tweet them to us at yale or
email them to social media
yale.edu
mark thanks for being with us thanks
eric it's great to be here so let's
start with the definition um what is
sustainable agriculture what are
sustainable agriculture practices
so sustainable agriculture looks
different everywhere in the world
because sustainable agriculture is a way
of thinking about what a particular
space needs
and what is going to be the system that
will be there for the long haul
so that means that a sustainable farm in
connecticut could look very very
different from a sustainable farm in
iowa or a sustainable farm in the
highlands of peru
so
since we're in connecticut why don't we
talk about what a sustainable farm looks
like here
sure well a sustainable farm in
connecticut is one which is going to
think broadly about what are the needs
of the people who are on this particular
parcel of land what are the needs of the
people who are actually eating the food
and i think in this part of the world
you'll find a sustainable farm which is
much more responsive to the needs of the
urban consumer because this is an urban
area
and so you'll probably find crops that
are high value coming out of smaller
acreages that really focus on how to
manage soil in a very diverse you know
terrain there's a lot of diversity in
connecticut's terrain everywhere from
the flatlands and the river valleys up
to some of the highlands which might be
better suited for grazing so you could
find all sorts of different sustainable
farms in the connecticut landscape so
are there
are there universal aspects of
sustainable agriculture that are going
to hold true in vancouver or in
connecticut or in europe or africa
middle east there definitely are and
these are principles instead of recipes
okay so you want to think about what the
broad underlying principles that will
apply all over the world are rather than
saying here's a prescribed recipe or a
checklist of what sustainable food is so
some of those principles which might be
relevant to the kind of people who come
out of yale the first is big picture
thinking
are you looking long-term are you
thinking about the kind of agriculture
which is going to be there for the long
haul and are you thinking about all of
its connections to the broad landscape
around it are you thinking of the people
who eat the food are you thinking about
the people who grow the food all the
things that go in all the things that
come out
another principle might be dealing with
complexity and diversity the fact that
you have to think about all of these
different elements that change all the
time and that leads us to a third one
which might be adaptability the fact
that we're in a changing planet the
climate is changing culture is changing
population is changing a sustainable
farm can't stand still
and so if you think of some of these
things adaptability dealing with
complexity and general big picture
thinking for the long term and a broad
landscape those are some of the
underlying principles of sustainable
agriculture so so let's talk about a
specific farm tell us about yale farm
what does it grow who does the growing
what do you do with the produce that you
that you grow
so the yale farm is right here on yale's
main campus it's up on edwards street
and it is primarily for teaching it's
primarily as the spot where yale
students can enrich their classroom
experience and gain experience with the
kind of things that are hard to hard to
get to in the classroom basically
so
it grows a little bit of everything
because we want to teach a little bit of
everything and so it's not only the
roughly 100 different cultivars of
vegetables fruits berries herbs the food
crops that are grown there we also think
beyond that we grow fiber crops fuel
crops fiber crops could be things like
flax fuel crops could be things like
canola we have animals in that system
too so there's the laying hens that
rotate around the fields and the whole
thing is orchestrated kind of as a
symphony to try and get all these pieces
working together so that we're thinking
about what will be planted next year and
what was planted the year before
trying to work with nature rather than
control nature and work against it and
those are some of the underlying
principles that we want to be able to
give our students experience with
so give us a sense if you would just uh
list some of the different types of
crops and some of the uh some of the
best crops uh
well right now we've just wrapped up the
main harvest so all of the tender crops
and heat loving crops that you would
have got at the farmer's market where we
sell every saturday those are kind of
winding down for the year so less of the
tomatoes and eggplants and peppers now
we're moving more into the root things
so you're getting these wonderfully
sweet carrots all different varieties of
beets things that are coming from the
roots of the plant and these will keep
the markets going strong for the next
couple of months and then we move into
some of the season extension which we do
in our high tunnels which are basically
passive solar-powered greenhouses that
make the crops think they're on the
properties on the property yeah
yeah so that allows us to actually
extend the season
the crops are in an environment which is
more typical of being a number of
degrees south of where we actually are
and so that way we get tender leafy
greens all the way through the winter so
it's a year-round farm 12 months of the
year we're harvesting we're growing okay
and
if you would talk about
how you practice sustainable agriculture
at yale farm so just to give a very
specific example that people maybe can
extrapolate from
in other environments what are you doing
at yale farm as you grow all this
produce
and manage the animals that makes it
sustainable agriculture
okay i'll give one example we're using a
new
kelp based fertilizer on the farm which
is basically a research project that
we're doing in partnership
with an oysterman
our neighborhood oysterman bren smith
who runs the thimble island oyster
company is trying to find ways to
diversify the shellfish crop
into all sorts of sea vegetables
one thing you can do with sea plants is
use them as fertilizer
there's a wonderful kind of
complementarity
between the kind of nutrients that come
from kelp and the kind of nutrients that
we don't have at the yale farm
so in new england we have these rocky
soils that are very very low in
potassium it just so happens that where
most of the photosynthesis is happening
in this part of the world in the oceans
you have these sea vegetables that are
producing huge amounts of potassium and
so we're taking these sea plants
bringing them to the nearby yale farm
and finding that match between what the
ecosystem is providing and what our
particular farm agri ecosystem needs
so we're asking what's available locally
and how can local resources complement
some of the deficiencies that prohibit
us from having the most productive farm
we can and so that's what we're looking
at what's available locally and how can
we use that in a system that makes sense
for yale
so if the kelp weren't available or you
hadn't stumbled upon
your your kelp provider or this idea
but you still wanted to and of course
needed to fertilize what you're growing
what might be just as a point of
contrast a typical
non or unsustainable
source
right you can always find sources of
nutrients but sometimes they don't come
from renewable sources
and this is quite typical is that you
would use
for example
mineral nutrients that are basically
coming from mines
that are coming from places where you
have a finite supply and phosphorus is
an excellent example of this uh we're
very concerned on the global scale about
what we do when the phosphorus runs out
which will happen
so i'm sorry go ahead no oh no so you
you have to consider everything that's
coming onto the farm
and again the big picture thinking what
are the long-term prospects for that
particular input yeah and uh are we
using a source which is going to be
there forever so that that would seem to
be a universal aspect of sustainable
agriculture absolutely you've got to
think long term and thinking long term
means everything that goes into this
farm is that going to be there uh a
hundred years from now 200 years from
now
i'm going to uh take a question now uh
from
a viewer this is from tracy
and
she asks why does the sustainable food
movement seem
so focused on pig pig roasts uh
grass-fed cows and the like instead of
focusing on what what she calls the
truly sustainable shift toward
plant-based eating and there's a lot of
uh sort of premises uh in there i don't
know if you agree with them all or not
but what do you have to say to tracy
okay this may sound counter-intuitive
and we just had a great pig roast on the
weekend
the reason why we do have some of these
focus focused events on meat is because
we would really like people to eat less
meat so this is the counterintuitive bit
i'm going to give a small example of a
project that i was working on at the
university of british columbia
we had first nations communities there
where there was a lot of tobacco abuse
okay and it was clear that the abuse of
this tobacco was not helped basically by
nagging by getting parents to say hey
stop smoking stop doing that you're
doing this wrong here's the rule
but it might be helped by actually
bringing tobacco back to a level where
it was culturally valued say hey here
was the role that tobacco had in your
cultural traditions
respect it
and you end up using less of it not
abusing it
so what i'm saying is if we respect meat
and we value it and say that this is
actually like one of the most valuable
food sources that we have
you know it so much goes into it we need
to stop treating it as though it's just
a throwaway product
and if we actually value it then we
might end up at the point where we enjoy
high quality meat a small amount of it
and it can come from sustainable sources
but keeping it there i think is the way
that we actually engage the broad
audience
because if we take an extreme position
and say that our definition of
sustainability prohibits a whole list of
things that people enjoy then it's very
hard to bring them to the table it's
very hard to get a broad audience you're
kind of left with a niche audience so we
want to have an audience that's already
converted as it were probably yeah so we
want to have impact impact means we need
to have everybody at the table and so i
do think that uh showing that meat can
be something which is valuable as a
small part of a meal
can keep those people at the table
rather than turning them off from the
beginning so talk about why
you want to encourage people to eat less
meat
it's not it's not merely an ideological
position right there's there are
practical ramifications to the way that
meat is produced for mass consumption am
i right
absolutely and you know it's been said
that the way we eat is the way that we
use the planet
and that's true but it's mostly true
when you say the way that we eat meat is
the way that we use the planet
so
because they are you know one line up
the food chain from the plants
it means that a lot more resources a lot
more land is required to produce meat
than it is to produce protein from its
vegetable counterpart
so every time that we eat meat we are we
have a hot far higher impact on the land
that we use
it's also the major source of many of
the greenhouse gas emissions that are
coming from the food system how is that
well you know worldwide the food system
is uh you know pushing a third of the
greenhouse gas emissions in most
countries it actually outweighs every
other sector that is a contribution
yeah yeah exactly and most of those are
actually coming from livestock
production from animal production
so in some cases it is because of the
methane
that animals produce when they transform
biologically yeah biologically and they
were always producing this but there
were far fewer rumen animals on the
planet yeah you know 100 years ago than
there were today so you can actually
have a much more sustainable number we
did for millennia and millennia but
we've just kind of overshot that right
now with the number of animals that we
have
you know grazing and converting
the other one is actually fertilizer
production and uh so if you take those
two basically the way we're producing
fertilizers and the sheer number of
ruminant animals that we have ruminant
ruminants those are the animals that can
actually convert
grasses to
food that humans can eat so we can't eat
grass
cattle who are ruminants they can
and so it's an incredible transformation
there's a lot of agricultural land in
the world that is really not suitable
for cultivation
but with cattle on it you can turn it
into food for humans okay but the
process of doing that methane
now what about
also
water is there a relationship between
water consumption and um a meaningful
one and and the huge volume of cattle
that are grown for meat purposes yeah
cattle are really thirsty yeah and so
they require an incredible amount of
water and also the production of their
feed requires a lot of water too
um
you know without a doubt if you track
the water that goes into producing uh
you know a pound of beef versus say a
pound of soy or some high protein plant
thing
you end up with a whole lot more water
going into the cattle than going into
the soy production water is a tricky one
though because as you can imagine uh the
volume of water available and how
renewable that is changes everywhere you
are on the planet so making a blanket
statement about how much water
it takes to produce a particular pound
of beef probably doesn't hold true it
really depends on where that beef comes
from and that's where the place-based
nature of sustainability becomes
paramount you have to think about what's
available locally and whether those
resources are locally renewable or
whether they are locally non-renewable
so
if if
what are some of the sacrifices that um
that at least that first world societies
may really need to make
in order to practice sustainable
agriculture and make it
not just something to aspire to but
default i mean it seems that
if we want to
not transport you know
uh strawberries from uh california to
connecticut in the middle of the winter
or something then we may have to simply
forego strawberries in the middle of the
winter is that is that um well let me
stop there and just ask a question
we may want to forgo strawberries in the
middle of the winter
it may end up with better strawberries
for us when they're in the season things
that we enjoy more and ultimately
something where we get a better diet at
the end of the day out of
i mean i think the two things that
we would have to sacrifice
are not really very big sacrifices
one is that we would eat less meat and
so the net result of that is that we
would have fewer saturated fats in our
diets and so we may be sacrificing if
that's the right word
a whole ream of health outcomes heart
diseases these kind of things
the other is that we would sacrifice the
freedom to waste as much food as we
currently waste which is about a third
of everything that comes into our
kitchens so around the world we're
looking at about a third of all the food
that could be eaten by humans never
getting eaten by humans
and
so if you're asking questions about
sustainability the two big ones in my
mind are actually the amount of meat
that we expect to consume and the amount
of waste that we expect to be throwing
away
and so
in my mind those two big facets are not
really what i would call sacrifices
they're probably those wonderful
win-wins ones where we actually end up
with a healthier diet where we end up
with some improved health outcomes at
the end of the day spend less on
healthcare hopefully
and uh end up basically with a system
that we enjoy more end up with food that
becomes part of life is something that
we enjoy rather than something that we
have to get out of the way so that we
can get onto the business of doing other
things let me take another question uh
this is fro
from toru he uh facebooked us and asks
is sustainable agriculture profitable to
farmers
it has to be profitable if it's
sustainable
if a farm business
can't stay in business then it is not
sustainable
as i said the first tenet of
sustainability in my mind is big picture
thinking
and so you got to think is this the kind
of farm which my great-grandchildren if
i'm running the farm will my
great-grandchildren be proud of what's
being left behind
in terms of this farm is it something
which will be thriving is it something
which will be profitable and so yeah if
a farm is not going to stay in business
then it's obviously not sustainable
and i do think that there's lots of
examples where the tenants of
environmental sustainability looking at
the conservation of biophysical
resources
are also very compatible with financial
profitability in many cases especially
in this part of the world farmers have
been able to access new niche markets as
well as new markets entirely some of
them which are growing very quickly that
they never would have been able to
access if they hadn't shown that they
were holding to these different
environmental social economic values
that consumers are now willing to pay
more for
so yeah there's there's new markets that
are opening up because people are moving
towards sustainability rather than the
other way around is there an example
anywhere in the world of a
of a large scale
farm producing a lot of uh food
for you know commercial markets
that operates under you know fully
sustainable agricultural principles you
bet actually i mean you've described
something which i believe is the fastest
growing sector of agriculture in the
united states something that we like to
call agriculture of the middle not the
very very small farms and not the very
very large farms but the ones that have
balanced out kind of a scale
sustainability profitability in in a
very interesting way i was just speaking
with
one of the growers from nyman ranch who
yale dining uses okay and nyman ranches
diamond ranch operates all across the
country
but this particular rancher was actually
talking about how their ranch was saved
this was out in wyoming i believe
but you know you're talking about a uh
grazing area which was roughly on par
with the total size of all the
agriculture in connecticut
and you know they were able to take a
farm that was teetering on the brink of
collapse
and because
their daughter came home from college
and said hey
all the students right now are demanding
sustainable food they want sustainable
food in the dining halls
and they realize hey if we market this
in a different way if we kind of change
the way that we're producing the food
add some values to it
we can basically
market it as saying hey we're doing all
the things that you're asking for you
know the college students said that we
don't want confinement animals and we
want animals that have been grazed in a
sustainable way that aren't over grazing
we want all of these system things in
our food and it opened up a new market
for this ranch it's now flourishing not
just economically but also ecologically
so where it used to be a stripped soil
whose nutrients were declining where the
health of the crops was suffering the
health of the animals were suffering
today it's absolutely thriving they've
been adding organic matter to the soil
each year they can get more animals off
of a given area because it's pastured i
think in a very intelligent way and so
they're adding to the soil they're
giving back to nature they're thriving
economically and it's all because you
had an institutionally sized market
something like yale is doing right now
this is where we get all of our
many of our meat products from the
dining halls
this was an example where it was a large
institution saying we demand a
sustainable practice and having the
market open up for that sustainable
practice meant that a farm went from the
brink of collapse to absolutely thriving
and it's thriving both economically but
also ecologically so these things can be
so compatible and there's many examples
and a growing number of examples so just
to summarize what are you know the two
or three most important sustainable
agriculture practices that nyman ranch
has put into place
i guess i'll stop the question sure i
mean i think the most important one is
concentrated grazing
it used to be that you would let the
animals kind of roam freely
and it is in a way that never really
happened historically
looking at how
ruminants again those animals eat grass
behave on the savannah of africa
they don't spread out broadly like they
do on a cattle range 50 years ago
they huddle together in these tight
herds and they basically like graze down
an area
very intensely and then they don't
return to that area for a year
and it turns out that that pattern of
moving around in tight clusters grazing
down an area and then moving on
giving the soil and the plants a chance
to recover
that was the system that these ruminants
and grasses co-evolved in
what nyman ranch is doing is a form of
biomimicry like the engineers like to
call it which is basically mimicking a
natural ecosystem so those animals now
those cattle are being moved around in
these very tight herds it means that the
rancher has to move a whole lot of
fencing much more often it's much more
labor intensive but you end up with a
process that builds up the soil adds
carbon to the soil keeps the plants
healthier keeps the animals healthier
another thing that they're doing which i
would consider a sustainable
agricultural practice is they're paying
great attention to the welfare of those
animals
so
we've had all sorts of i think
innovations in animal welfare as people
have demanded a better system as
consumers as institutions have demanded
better systems to attend to animal
welfare and so they've looked at the
lives that those cattle are living
basically you know from the time they're
born the range land that they're on how
they're moved around how they end up
ending their lives and what are the
areas within there that the conventional
system was behaving unethically how
could we resolve those how could we add
ethics back into it and i think they've
done a very very good job at that so
certainly there are profound moral and
ethical reasons to
give animals the most comfortable lives
that they can have
but in what sense is that a sustainable
agriculture practice
well again you know i had said that we
need to think big what kind of
agriculture is going to be here for the
long term
if as a society
we stand up and say it's unacceptable to
treat animals in a way that is not
ethical which is not moral we don't
agree in
that's not sustainable agriculture
sustainable agriculture has to respond
to what people need
what they demand it has to respond i
think to the hopes and aspirations of
what people want globally and this goes
far beyond calories right people don't
want
calories per se you know that's not what
we go into a restaurant in order you
know we want food that actually we enjoy
that is reflective of our values and
that is something that contributes to a
good life
and we kind of got off the rails i think
with commodifying food stripping of all
of its value and what we're trying to do
is add value back into the food system
let's take another question
an email we received from chris who asks
or says that he's interested in ideas or
suggestions about how um he can get
started at home on a mini sustainable
food project uh of his own uh so
i'm not exactly sure what scale chris is
thinking about but presumably it's on
you know a small residential property
what can somebody do
there's a whole lot you can do just in
your backyard your balcony and actually
something which is very exciting as the
interest in urban agriculture has grown
so much in the last decade it's also
opened up many business opportunities
for people who are now providing urban
agricultural services and there's a
couple in new haven you can google them
i'm not going to make a an endorsement
for any of them right now but there's a
couple in new haven where people are
actually providing services saying hey
if you don't know where to start i'll
help you get going and that's a service
that they can provide and think about
what you might want in your backyard and
make suggestions as to the materials
that you might need to get going some of
the resources that might help you learn
uh how to respond to it and i think most
major cities now actually have people
who are starting up businesses and those
businesses are letting the backyard grow
or the balcony grower understand what
kind of system they could use so there's
a market now for that so let's um let's
assume that chris wants to grow some uh
plants yeah um what sort of plants might
you and let's assume chris is in
connecticut yeah what what what sort of
uh plants would you recommend that he
grow and you know what are the
what are some of the practices that
he might implement
well you can grow just about anything in
connecticut but you know the one which i
think will give you the most bang for
your buck as a starting backyard
gardener or starting urban farmer are
probably tomatoes
just because you know if you have them
undercover we have enough heat here in
connecticut that you can just grow
excellent tomatoes and the reason why i
think they're the most bang for your
buck
is that they are the uh fruit that least
resembles what the grocery store uh
equivalent has become so you know once
you've had the backyard uh you know kind
of hand grown tomato in all its glory
and you learn about that flavor eat it
for the first time
you'll say you know why did i even think
of having these tomatoes from the
supermarket i mean this this one has
flavor it's got taste it's got quality
it's got value i love it and it's really
hard to say that for the
very pink softball-like things that
you're often finding in grocery stores
these days so chris plants some tomatoes
in the backyard
what are what are some
to really boil it down some do's and
don'ts that he might
pursue
sure keep keep that plant healthy and uh
think about what the plant needs to stay
healthy the most important one is
actually a healthy soil
and uh if you're asking for principles
of sustainable agriculture that's one
that can be applied right from the
backyard all the way up to large large
acreages healthy soil
and so
in a backyard setting you're probably
going to have to construct that from
scratch but just making sure that it's
got lots of organic material lots of
compost
something which is going to have a lot
of nutrition be able to hang on to a lot
of water and basically release those
nutrients that the plant needs to stay
healthy and has a thriving little
ecosystem of its own right in the soil
and then you know you need to pay
attention to the obvious things making
sure that it's got light and it's got
water but it starts very much with a
healthy soil
let's take another question this one was
tweeted to us
from at nn33rd
who asks
about food waste a topic that you've
mentioned a few moments ago
but
this viewer is interested to know if you
think that legislation might be of some
sort might be a way
to address food waste
yeah i think there could be actually a
number of legislative options to pursue
um we're going to have to use a whole
bunch of different tools to address food
waste because food waste happens at all
different stages of the food chain and
each of those stages is going to require
a slightly different set of approaches
to actually remedy the fact that overall
it's still about a third of what we
could eat we're throwing away
and so yeah
when it comes to the kitchen
i think one of the most important things
we can do
is again to make food valuable again and
i'm using that not in terms of costly or
inaccessible i mean valuable as people
care about it it's something that you
wouldn't think of throwing away because
you cherish it you know something about
the story behind it you know that it's
going to be flavorful and delicious and
wonderful it becomes something which is
too important to you for a number of
reasons
to just toss
and when you're looking at institutional
approaches it completely changes it
might not be the consumer side but more
some of the systematic elements that are
currently exacerbating the food waste
problem
yale dining would be an interesting
example uh most of the residential
colleges are trailers now
so what does trailers have to do with
food race this is if you've got a bigger
plate you don't put as much on it if you
can't carry as much you don't bring more
than you can fit in your mouth these are
the dining halls yeah yeah that's right
the dining halls so i mean there's all
sorts of different approaches you can
take both from like the value of food
altogether to some of these like very
specific institutional interventions of
sort of saying okay what the system
right now is encouraging people to keep
wasting things interesting so that
reminds me the yale sustainable food
project is is a lot more than than the
yale farm oh yes so uh talk about just
some of the other major projects or
elements of the of the food project sure
the yale sustainable food project
although many people think of it as the
ale farm is a global thing so we work on
the farm both on our main campus as well
as well as the new west campus farm we
work in the classrooms and those are in
about 40 courses on the calendar each
year and they span every discipline you
can imagine food through an economics
lens food through a history lens through
an anthropology lens and then
increasingly we're working around the
world
and the reason for that is because right
to the beginning question
the sustainable farm
in one part of the world is not going to
be the same as a sustainable farm
somewhere else in the world
and so we can teach the principles of
sustainable agriculture the yale farm
but we can't teach the examples of
context-specific sustainable agriculture
without our students getting out in the
world
getting their boots on the ground and
seeing it firsthand
so the students who
start to learn about food at the yale
farm
increasingly and we hope it's going to
be up to 100 in a year they're going off
to farms around the world and learning
about okay what are the uh you know what
are the challenges what are the
opportunities and it's not just farming
because farming is the heart and soul of
the food system but it's not the food
system so our students are also going
off to businesses who are working on say
distribution marketing preparation maybe
the food distribution businesses maybe
the restaurants they're also working in
the health disciplines because
ultimately understanding how the food we
put in our bodies impacts our health is
one of these
big questions right now which is it's a
major missing link in the picture of how
we link the way we use the planet
to the way that people ultimately are
healthy and have good lives and so our
students
are going around the world to gain
experience in all of those different
subsystems of the larger food system
and learning about how it changes
everywhere you are in the world when
you've got a different cultural setting
a different biophysical setting how do
we have to approach this problem
differently when we're somewhere else in
the world
and so the sustainable food project is
global today and necessarily so because
the problems of yale and connecticut are
not the problems of the world
and yale students we produce some very
good leaders who i think understand uh
how to make policy changes how to make
financial changes how to look at the
systematic and systemic uh root causes
of the problem and figure out how to
tackle that big problem and to do that
they need a global perspective so we can
offer that
we've got just about 30 seconds for a
minute left let me ask you about some of
the some of the other ways that you
personally sort of practice agricultural
environmental sustainability
sustainability in your own life okay
um this is kind of a tough one because
probably the single most important thing
i could do if i was thinking about still
working in this country would be to move
to new york
and the reason for that is because in
this context it's actually living in
dense urban environments where you're
not heating a large space
where you don't have to rely on vast
distances to get to and from work and
all the amenities you need to go to
it's living small and local in that way
is the most important personal choice
you can make for sustainability
and so what i can do living in yale and
new haven is try and make new haven as
much like new york as i possibly can so
you know i bike here this morning
i will be biking off to try and eat at
some local restaurant or local coffee
shop after this interview and
working basically to embed the local
businesses the local farms
into all of my daily life like basically
trying to keep it local means that i
have to move around less
and living in a place which is close by
and is compact and enjoyable means i
have to eat less
and then of course you know i try and
watch food waste i try and eat foods
that are actually going to be
that i know are going to be delicious
too delicious to throw away and
i try and make meat the kind of
sought-after small pleasure not the
center of the plate but rather that uh
i guess kind of accompaniment to a plate
which is heavy in delicious plant-based
food
i'm going to try to sneak in one more
question that we got from twitter
by uh lorenzo wy which maybe stands for
wyoming i don't know
how would you encourage or compel
uh big agricultural companies like
monsanto to make their methods more
sustainable
oh that's a really interesting question
and actually i've been encouraged
because some of yale's graduates
who are deeply concerned about food
sustainability just passionate about it
have actually ended up working for very
very large firms and are now taking
roles within those firms as say chief
sustainability officers
or new high-ranking positions that
companies are opening up to give
sustainability leadership in that firm
and i actually think there is potential
for considerable transformation in some
of these big companies the the big like
possibility
is you look at the size of the supply
chains some of these companies take
walmart for an example and you think wow
if we could just just get
some internal changes
it would
resonate throughout a supply chain that
is bigger than most countries
and so something small from the inside
could end up being something very very
big on the outside so i do think there's
some potential there and i do think
actually by thinking of all the players
in the food system rather than focusing
on a subset uh we'll have a better
chance at actually achieving the kind of
sustainability we need so you so you you
would affect change or think it's most
likely to happen
effectively by getting people who have
who have absorbed and appreciate
sustainable food practices working
inside these companies yeah we say that
our product if you like is uh food
literate leaders
and the idea is that we need people
working on all fronts of the food system
inside big companies inside small
companies different approaches because
we have different challenges mark
bonford director of the yale sustainable
food project thank you very much for
joining us today and thanks to all of
you for watching at yale live please do
join us again next month
you